it seems like democrats want nothing to
do with joe and kamala the president and
his dismal approval ratings are seen as
toxic to democrats political health
candidates in tough races are refusing
to say if they want the president to
campaign with them and nevada's liberal
governor admitting he is not sure
whether biden should run for re-election
as for kamala harris she is trying to
reboot her image yet again
staffers reportedly want the vice
president on the road and doing more
interviews even though every single sit
down has been an utter disaster
okay
is biden a uh a hazard to the political
health of the democrats
so as i shared on the show maybe a few
days ago politicians are not the most
courageous people when it comes to
looking at politicians and saying i want
to be with that person they look at
polls
and you win elections by looking ahead
by looking forward and i give president
biden credit for recognizing when the
mistakes have been made and trying to
correct them he was here last week with
mayor adams mary adams is the most
dynamic figure in the party when it
comes to dealing with particularly city
issues and crime and the need to clean
up things two this president just two
weeks ago announced a 20 billion dollar
investment in columbus ohio with intel a
public-private partnership to help build
semi-conductor chips in ohio we talked
in the last segment i think the real
terrible legacy of what we're not doing
after covet is figuring out what we
didn't have in place when cobot hit and
how do we ensure we don't have that
problem again we have to build more
pharma more semiconductor chips more ai
more robots here finally he made
mistakes in afghanistan i think what
they they're done in building a
coalition to deal with ukraine and to
send i think the ultimate message a
powerful message to china that you're
not going to push us around at sullivan
blinken this president this congress and
democrats are on the page together now
if we want to talk about where people
are facing a little division just an
hour ago the senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell said to those in his
party including president trump and the
rnc you were wrong to censor liz cheney
and adam kinziger we may have problems i
think there was a rapper that said we
have 99 problems but we don't have that
one our leaders in our party pelosi
schumer and biden are on the same page
uh republicans don't seem to be this
afternoon yeah about this they've been
quiet
well i tell you president trump has been
criticized by mitch mcconnell and the
rnc these are just facts i i wouldn't
want to play that hand if i had it
either but those are the facts well you
know speaking of president trump what it
seems like in 2021 what the democrats
did was they tried to make the election
all about president trump and now it
appears that the democrats greg are
trying to make the election uh or the
republicans are trying to make the
election all about joe biden they think
that's a winning policy for them well i
think you know the the premise of this
segment is he hazardous i think that the
this ticket should come with a warning
may cause you to lose 48 states
the equivalent of smoking but
having said that it this is a good
problem to have you know they do they
are in the why it means they won so
they're so they have a terrible ticket
they have a terrible ticket they won
they they won with a terrible ticket
they're supposed to figure out the rest
later but now it's later and they still
haven't figured out what to do with this
terrible ticket um i when you think
about
it it's weird because like when harris
is missing you're like where is she and
then when she pops up you're reminded
why she's missing it's deliberate and
joe it's not like he's lost a step he's
lost an entire ladder so i understand
why they're like they're they're hidden
but but at some point you're going to
have to pull them up out of the ground
uh because uh you know
they're either gonna run or they're not
you know dana one of the things that
they say about kamala harris is that you
know she's been given these tough tough
assignments you know like the border and
you know she went down there and simply
said you know we need to follow the law
at the border that she'd be okay but
she's not considered is she redeemable
in every way i think that i think for
the problem with their ticket is that
the damage is already done the governor
of nevada when he said that he doesn't
think that biden should run again
um i don't know if i'm not saying that
exactly how he said it but basically he
was saying the quiet part out loud
that's what all the democrats think
but very few are willing to go on the
record but as his numbers continue to be
as low as they are more and more of
these democrats are going to continue to
separate themselves look at
just look at the mask mandates why do
you think phil murphy doesn't want to
hurt joe biden necessarily but he's like
i'm going to save myself and i'm going
to do the right thing and try to lead
the president to that position as for
kamala harris and her staff constantly
doing interviews about how she wants to
go out on the road
you don't have to keep doing interviews
about that just go out on the road and
then people will follow you and you can
do it's a great idea actually she could
create something like the kabla harris
good citizen award and she could go to
all these local communities and pick
bipartisan groups and say you know what
you're doing great things for america
and get great local press and she would
be out on the road and out of joe
biden's thinning hair
of doing a good interview without
laughing uh do you think she can answer
a question no she can't and i've made a
list oh these are the things that kamal
has done to the vice presidency so far
it's only been one year she's had a
reboot she's had a reset she's had a
relaunch
and she's redefined but she's also had a
shake-up an adjustment and a course
correction and then i heard a new one
today this isn't a reboot she's just
turning to chapter two
now if you had an ipad with this many
problems you'd return it this thing is a
shot it's a lemon it is a lemon
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else